en este vídeo quiero ver la matemática
que hay detrás de un préstamo
hipotecario y bueno de hecho no será
tanto un vídeo de finanzas más bien es
un vídeo mucho más matemático será
interesante porque nos enfocaremos en
algo que al menos yo me he preguntado ya
por mucho tiempo y bueno tú sabes
sacamos estos préstamos para comprar
casas digamos que sacas un préstamo de
200 mil pesos doscientos mil pesos y
bueno está asegurado este préstamo por
tu casa y bueno lo pagarás en un lapso
de 30 años lo que es equivalente a 360
meses porque bueno normalmente haces dos
pagos cada mes el interés normalmente se
compone mensualmente y digamos que estás
pagando un 6% en intereses estos son mis
intereses anuales que también se
componen mensualmente entonces 6%
dividido entre 12 hablamos de el punto
cinco por ciento entonces es el punto
cinco por ciento 5%
al mes
y bueno normalmente cuando tienes un
préstamo así tu agente hipotecario o tu
banquero va a meter estos números en
algún programa de cómputo y te dicen ok
muy bien mira a tu pago será de 1200 al
mes y si pagas esos 1200
al mes continuamente por 360 meses al
final de sus 360 meses habrás pagado a
tus 2 200 mil pesos más cualquier
interés que se haya acumulado eso te van
a decir así que bueno ya habrás pagado y
genial pero estos números no no es tan
sencillo llegar a ellos mira bueno te
voy a mostrar un ejemplo de cómo
funciona una hipoteca así que iniciamos
con que tienes un préstamo de 200 mil
pesos no haces pago alguno por qué harás
tu primer pago hasta dentro de un mes
así que esta cantidad será agravada por
el punto cinco por ciento hablamos del
primer día en el primer día te dan el
préstamo y después se va agravando por
el punto cinco por ciento
así que punto cinco por ciento como
decimal equivale a 0.005
así que en un mes con intereses esto
habrá crecido a 200.000 por 1.005 así
que 200.000 por 1.005 luego pagará 2200
así que será menos 1200 y así queda en
este primer mes y después para el mes
siguiente sea lo que sea que sobre será
otra vez agravado por el punto 5 %
entonces por 1.005 luego el próximo mes
regresarás y pagarás estos 1.200 otra
vez entonces menos 1200 y esto pasará
360 veces 360 veces así va hasta 360
veces los seguirás haciendo y al final
tendrás una enorme expresión como por
360 paréntesis de hecho y todo será
igual a 0 porque después de tu último
pago habrás terminado de pagar la casa
pero va a haber
como en general cómo llegamos a este a
este pago el adecuado a este número
llamémosle p hay alguna forma matemática
para averiguarlo para hacerlo hay que
ponernos más abstractos digamos que el
el es igual a la cantidad de préstamo
cantidad de préstamo y digamos que if i
es el interés mensual interés mensual
baja ahora n n es el número de meses
número de meses con los que estamos
tratando
por último p es igual al pago mensual
así que p es igual al pago mensual tu
pago hipotecario mensual alguno del cual
es interés y otra parte es el pago
principal pero es la misma cantidad que
pagarás cada mes para pagar ese préstamo
más los intereses así que es el pago
mensual
esta misma expresión si la escribo en
términos abstractos inicias con una
cantidad de préstamo esta es l y después
de un mes se compone a lo multiplicas
por uno más y uno más
y en estas situaciones 1.005 luego pagas
un pago mensual así que menos p y eso es
al final de un mes luego tienes también
una cantidad sobrante de tu préstamo y
eso se acumula al siguiente mes luego
pagadas nuevamente y esto se se repite y
se repite 360 veces o bueno en este caso
n veces porque estamos en abstracto el
mundo abstracto de finanzas así que
bueno para para que se entienda se va a
repetir en exceso bueno tendríamos que
poner en el paréntesis en el paréntesis
y después de hacer esto en fs es todo
será igual a cero entonces bueno me
pregunta la principal por la cual yo
hago este vídeo es cómo resolvemos para
p sabemos la cantidad de préstamos la
tasa de
es mensual sabemos la cantidad de meses
como sabemos a que es igual p no parece
ser una expresión algebraica sencilla
así que hay que ver cómo le vamos a
hacer
veamos si podemos acomodarlo de una
manera generalizada entonces iniciamos
con un ejemplo sencillo con n igual a 1
quien es igual a 1 entonces nuestra
situación se va a ver algo así sacas tu
préstamo lo compone xa un mes sería uno
más y luego pagas tu pago mensual esto
representa una hipoteca que se paga en
un mes así que después de ese pago
habrás liquidado tu préstamo eres libre
entonces resolveremos para penn así que
igual a cero y resolvemos para pepe es
igual a l por uno más
y si divides ambos lados por uno más y
tenemos
p sobre uno más y es igual a él y bueno
dirás tuve ya resolví este para p o sea
porque haces eso de dl porque resuelves
para l lo hago porque quiero mostrarte
un patrón a que que surgirá aquí
mágicamente con n igualados inicias con
tu cantidad de préstamo que se compone
para un mes haces tu pago y luego lo que
sobra sobra cierta cantidad eso se
compone a un mes haces tu segundo pago
está hipoteca y necesita dos pagos y ya
terminaste hiciste los pagos principales
y los pagos de interés ahora hay que
resolver para p entonces voy a colorear
las p es bueno esta p de color rosa sumó
pesa ambos lados así que está verde esta
p verde será igual a todo este asunto
entonces bueno vamos a hacer esto sí que
se ve mucho pero no lo es tanto en p es
igual a l por uno más y menos la p color
rosa
aunque son la misma p sólo quiero
mostrarte que sucede algebraica mente
uno más y ahora si divides ambos lados
por uno más y vas a obtener que sobre
uno más y es igual a todo esto l por uno
más y menos para perros y está
y ya entonces ahora sumemos pe a ambos
lados sumando la p color rosa a ambos
lados de la ecuación obtenemos temas p
sobre uno más y es igual a l por uno más
y ahora divido a ambos lados por uno más
y entonces te va a quedar la p color
rosa sobre 11 más
y bueno la masa p verde pero estamos
dividiendo entre uno más y entonces nos
va a quedar uno más y al cuadrado así
que uno más y al cuadrado es igual a l
igual a él y bueno como puedes ver algo
interesante estar aquí ocurriendo te
recomiendo los vídeos de valor presente
aquí tomas un pago los descuentos por tu
tasa de interés mensual y obtienes la
cantidad de préstamos aquí tomas cada
uno de tus pagos los descuentos lo
divides entre uno más la tasa de interés
elevado a la potencia que corresponde al
número de meses lo que hace es
esencialmente es tomar el valor presente
de tus
y una vez más obtienes tu cantidad de
préstamos y lo que vas a hacer aunque
tal vez quieras hacerlo por ti solo si
quieres practicar un poco tu álgebra si
lo haces con un igual a tres y bueno no
lo voy a hacer por el tiempo pero con n
igual a 3 él es igual a p sobre 1 más y
más p sobre 1 más y al cuadrado pero no
más y al cuadrado más p sobre 1 más y al
cubo esto lo obtienes con el igual a 3
hazlo y verás que si es el mismo
procedimiento que hicimos acá habrá que
hacer algo de álgebra pero de qué sale
sale no tomara tanto tiempo en general
te he mostrado que que podemos escribir
la cantidad de préstamo como el valor
presente de todos los pagos podríamos
decir en general que la cantidad de
préstamo la cantidad de préstamo
generalizando esto a n podríamos decir
que es igual a bueno aquí voy a
factorizar las pes entonces pongo p
por 1 sobre 1 más y más 1 sobre 1 más y
esto al cuadrado más y así seguirá hasta
n veces uno sobre uno más y a la n
cierro paréntesis y bueno esto ahora
quizás bueno lo reconozcas observa lo
bien ahora cierra los ojos voy a
escribir el nombre de esto esto es magia
no lo sabrás todavía qué emoción qué
emoción
esto es una no voy a decir nombres ok ya
abre los ojos esto es una serie
geométrica guau qué bonito sí exacto a
que no te lo esperabas entonces esto
podemos saber la suma total entonces
bueno esta es la suma de uno sobre uno
más y donde uno más y lo elevamos a la
jota aquí
y es desde jota igual a 1 hasta aquí
está uno esto es elevado a la 1 entonces
igual a uno hasta jota igual a n y eso
es exactamente esta serie geométrica
veamos hay una manera si existe una
manera sencilla de resolver esto porque
bueno no lo queremos hacer 360 veces no
no no es demasiado aunque si
obtendríamos un número que igual se
divide entre l y resuelve es para p solo
para simplificar la matemática voy a
escribir aquí una definición digamos que
r es igual a uno sobre uno más y llamaré
a toda esta suma la voy a llamar a todo
esto ese y si decimos que es igual a
cada uno de estos términos entonces éste
será igual será igual a esto será r a la
primera potencia y acá será r al
cuadrado como lo puedes ver tú aquí en
estos dos entonces escribo más r al
cuadrado y bueno así se va a seguir r el
cubo más más más más hasta r
n y bueno te mostraré ahora un pequeño
truco
yo siempre olvido de estas fórmulas así
que una buena manera de obtener una suma
de una serie geométrica esto lo puedes
usar para encontrar la suma de una serie
geométrica infinita aquí aquí es una
serie finita entonces multiplicamos r
por s igual si multiplicamos cada uno de
estos poderes edad
r por r sería ir al cuadrado r al
cuadrado por r sería r al cubo y así te
vas a seguir más y luego ya aquí ahora
acá falta un término aquí sería r a la n
1 y ese x r sería r a la n iv r a la n
por r sería r más r a la n más uno todos
estos se multiplican por r y como puedes
ver los puse bajo el mismo exponente
ahora lo que podríamos hacer es restar
estos términos verdes de estos términos
morados entonces si si decimos s - r por
s que obtenemos s - r por s
estoy restando esta
de esta otra línea r a la 10
pues eso ahí no hay nada o sea ahí no
hay nada entonces ahí sería herrera 1
pero luego el r al cuadrado menos r al
cuadrado ahí es 0 y se van cruzando
estos se van cancelando todos se van a
cancelar claro menos este ere a la n 1
este es el último término ese no se
cancela
qué lindo truco verdad o vaya que sí
entonces menos ere a la n más uno y
factor izando aquí una s obtenemos s por
1 - r hay factores de la s eso es igual
a ere a la 1 - r a la n 1 y obtienes
aquí la suma esta suma es igual
ese es igual a r sin poner aquí el 1
como exponente r nada más así que es r -
r a la n 1 sobre 1 - r
1 - r a esto equivale nuestra suma
definiendo a r de esta manera ahora
podemos reescribir toda esta fórmula
a podemos decir que nuestro préstamo que
l es igual a nuestro pago mensual el
cual en este caso voy a poner en verde
así que esto es x r - r a la n 1 sobre 1
- r y cierro paréntesis ahora bien si yo
quiero si yo quiero resolver para p voy
a multiplicar ambos lados por el inverso
de eso y obtengo que p es igual a lp es
igual a él por el inverso de esto
entonces por el inverso es 1
r por 1 - r sobre r - r a la n 1 donde r
r es esto de aquí y hemos terminado así
es como puedes resolver para tu pago
hipotecario a ver a hay que aplicarlo ok
para que quede más claro
digamos que tu préstamo es igual a 200
mil pesos y que tu tasa de interés es
del 6% aquí es 6% anual lo cual es punto
5% al mes
punto 5% al mes
es igual a 0.005 eso es la tasa mensual
y digamos que es un préstamo a 30 años
30 años que son 360 meses y bueno
hagamos el experimento lo primero que
queremos saber es el valor de nuestra r
entonces bueno hay que ver cuál es el
valor de nuestra r así que bueno veamos
r es uno sobre uno más y dónde y es así
que uno dividido por uno más siglo cual
es punto 005 entonces uno más y lo cual
es punto cero 0 5 eso es nuestra tasa de
interés mensual y bueno cierro el
paréntesis lo cual es igual a punto 99 5
es el valor de nuestra r esta
calculadora no no guarda datos así que
la voy a bajar para poder escribirlo así
que
dejar la rastro era es igual a haber
bueno ya sabemos a cuánto vale eres
igual apuntó bueno mejor lo pongo con
000 puntos 99 5 lo acabamos de usar es
esto de acá y bueno estoy perdiendo un
poco de precisión pero creo que estará
bien al fin y al cabo solamente quiero
darte la idea así que cuál será la
cantidad de pago multiplicamos nuestra
cantidad de préstamo que son 200 mil
pesos aquí tengo 200 mil pesos así está
200 mil x
1 - r así que es 11 - punto 995 /
así que así que cierro paréntesis r lo
cual es punto 1995 abro paréntesis
así que punto 9 95 y después menos punto
9 95 otra vez elevado a la ns 360
entonces será 360 más uno elevado al a
361 eso no lo puedo hacer mi cabeza no
tengo ese superpoder pero la calculadora
así entonces cierro paréntesis y el
resultado es este si lo haces con un
poco más de precisión te saldrá un poco
menos que esto entonces será 1200
aproximadamente y ya con esto pudimos
saber el valor del pago hipotecario así
que p es igual a 1200
p es igual a 1200 elegante no crees los
cálculos fueron muy elegantes y
averiguamos algo con lo que nos topamos
día a día además de tu sorpresa y bueno
ya sabemos las matemáticas que hay
detrás de todo esto